dr. dre produces your first album right
how do you get dr. Dre who's probably
the biggest producer and he doesn't just
happen right you know if dr. Dre chooses
to produce your record that means he
sees something big in you how do you at
that age get dr. Dre interested in you
there's Topp Dogg make the introduction
what happens is a lot of work prior to
that makes the introduction I put out a
lot of material on me at Topp Dogg's
just mix tell extension demos and you
know you never know how far your music
may go just crazy because the you go
from writing these songs in your
mother's kitchen you know someone
telling you that people of this caliber
this magnitude has heard the slam out
and now dr. Dre is yeah you got to be
pretty good if you get discovered that
way so somebody somehow one of your
tapes ends up in dr. Dre's hands and he
goes oh this kid's got it right I think
a YouTube video as well yeah [ __ ] me and
my bro Dave shadow little rinky-dink
camera made it work that's what I want
should be one of my best videos today
right that was it like for you when okay
you're still a kid making mixtapes and
stuff and you know you getting your
confidence going and you're working on
other artists albums and all that stuff
right but all of a sudden when dr. Dre
gives you the call hmm where are you
does he call you does he come visit you
have that all go down I was on tour man
with my brother j-roc and I was his
height man he was he hadn't weren't even
the mainland try one man shake I was
just there shun I know you know and my
boy Ali was eating at Chili's on
everything I've seen that Chili's and we
got a call like yo dr. Dre likes your
music and you hung up yeah we hung up oh
my that give you the chills you might
have blown it right there out of blowing
it with another call came in from
somebody else then another car came
somebody was like yo they trying to
reach out and figure out who you wait
you know do you feel like your entire
life changes when you get that call yeah
definitely because it's is evolving when
you get in the studio
is it intimidating yeah I tell you this
the first time was the moment I've knew
I've arrived because I'm not only
meaning it's not an introduction he
plays a beat and say write to it so
you're working I want to see your
collaborate I want to see it is really
you in other words you're going yeah
right he doesn't know for sure that you
made those tapes but he's also saying to
you you're my equal right I'm not coming
in here
you're now we're going to business again
it gives me the chills
yeah it definitely is is it it's a
moment where you gotta say where I say
it to myself this is it